der kampf gegen korona ist zähle die
infektionszahlen steigen nicht mehr so
stark an
aber die todeszahlen bleiben weiter hoch
und die mutationen bereiten sorgen und
es hakt bei produktion und lieferung der
impfstoffe die nerven kostüme vieler
eltern die sind inzwischen dünn und in
der wirtschaft stehen einige unternehmer
vor der pleite
das handeln von einer bund länder
konferenz zur nächsten mit beschlüssen
die dann irgendwie doch nicht für alle
gelten das nervt lockdown frust brauchen
wir eine neue corona strategien unser
thema in der phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
schönen guten abend ganz herzlich
willkommen aus berlin nicht dafür meine
gäste vorstellen hier im studio
professor klaus stöhr er ist virologe
und epidemiologe und er war leiter des
global influenza programms und sarahs
forschungskoordinator dwh also der
weltgesundheitsorganisation danach dann
tätig in der impfstoff entwicklung und
forschung bei der pharmafirma novartis
und sie begrüße cerstin gammelin sie ist
die stellvertretende leiterin des
parlamentsbüros der süddeutschen zeitung
zu guten abend und zugeschaltet ist uns
professor maximilian maja er es
politikwissenschaftler an der
universität bonn und er hat mit anderen
wissenschaftler ein papier verfasst für
eine neue strategie
schönen guten namen nach bonn herr meier
guten abend und ich begrüße in rostock
klaus ruhe madsen er ist der
oberbürgermeister der schönen hansestadt
dort er ist dänische unternehmer
möbelhändler war er vorher
und der ist jetzt bekannt geworden weil
rostock in der ganzen zeit der pandemie
ganz niedrige infektionszahlen hatte
schönen guten abend herr madsen moin
moin moin moin ihre ins tendenz ist
immer noch unter 50 41 sind es heute
glaube ich und sie haben die rostocker
209.000 einwohner und insgesamt nur 13
tote wenn ich es richtig gelesen habe
herr madsen wie schaffen sie das
aktuell ist mit 21 sondern wieder 34
darüber freuen wir uns natürlich sehr
die aktuellen zahlen sind heute und ja
wir waren immer sehr sehr schnell
unterwegs mit maßnahmen sehr konsequent
in der umsetzung wir haben deutlich über
die empfehlungen getestet wir haben sehr
schnell wird zum beispiel den rostocker
zoo als erstes in deutschland
geschlossen aber auch wiederum als
erstes in deutschland wieder eröffnet
die philharmonie haben wir als erstes
wieder eröffnet und so waren wir halt
immer sehr schnell und zügig unterwegs
wir haben und das ist glaube ich das
allerwichtigste mit meinen
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter ist
geschafft im gesundheitsamt immer
nachzuvollziehen wenn jemand sich
infiziert hatte wo es herkam immer die
kontakt hätten geschlossen also bis
heute gab es da keine überraschung da
aber das ist am ende des tages der große
erfolg in meine verwaltung geschafft
und das hält uns auf spur und darüber
bin ich natürlich sehr froh woher
wussten sie dass dass es richtig ist zum
beispiel direkt schnell und viel zu
testen ganz am anfang gab es ja noch gar
nicht so viele tests ja also dabei ist
tatsächlich so heuer wieder der chef vom
rk ii hatten ein vortrag gesagt es kommt
nur auf die oberbürgermeister und wenn
an möglichst die verwaltung und
bürokratie über bord werfen und alles zu
tun es geht um leben und tod und
daraufhin bin ich nach hause gefahren
der rosstag und habe sofort ein team
zusammengestellt wir haben auch sehr
schnell ein testcenter aufgebaut und ich
habe hier vor ort mit einem biotech
unternehmen vereinbart wie wir testen
machen können so haben wir uns das
krankenhauspersonal pfleger polizisten
feuerwehr rettungsdienste auch teile der
verwaltung testen können und wir haben
auch die ambulante pflegedienste das
angeboten
ich hatte das gefühl dass es immer
besser ist möglichst viele menschen zu
testen sind ein stück weit so wenn sie
in einen raum treten und sie es ist
dunkel voll mit menschen sie wissen dass
die die infiziert sind blau angelaufen
sind dann macht es schon sinn das licht
anzumachen und nicht erst zu warten bis
irgendwo in der ecke jemand hustet und
dann feststellen dass da jemand steht
mit einer taschenlampe der blau ist also
lieber möglichst viel licht im raum
bringen und so haben wir eigentlich die
ganze zeit auch immer gearbeitet
versucht zu schauen was können wir mit
welchen maßnahmen wie umsätzen um
möglichst viel werden wir auf der suche
sind licht im raum zu haben
okay das heißt sie haben eine strategie
gefunden mit dem virus zu leben
die halb die ganz gut funktioniert ja
also bisher ist es tatsächlich so wir
haben aber auch immer wenn ich heute
irgendwo aus deutschland ein
gesundheitsamt hat aufgegeben sie kommen
nicht mehr hinterher habe ich immer
gesagt 100 noch weitere leute ich hatte
meine schulen bereits schon sehr früh
geschlossen da hatten wir insgesamt nur
in rostock vier infizierte und da hatte
ich aber nachgelesen
infektions gesetz dass wenn ein pandemie
kommt muss man vor der pandemie die den
loddar und machen sonst hat er überhaupt
gar keinen effekt deswegen haben wir
sehr schnell gehandelt
wir haben konzerte abgesagt
großveranstaltungen und ja dann habe ich
alle mitarbeiter ich habe etwa 2400
mitarbeiter ich hatte in unseren eigenen
konzepte gelesen wir brauchen genau 439
mitarbeiter um den laden am leben zu
halten und alle anderen freigestellt
deshalb gewerbeaufsicht die haben wir
zum gesundheitsamt dazu gezogen sagt die
brauchen wir für die konzept verfolgung
und im nachgang habe ich dann immer mehr
leute dort eingebaut im gesundheitsamt
zum beispiel habe ich gesagt aus dem
grünen können wir auch sehr gut
mitarbeiter nehmen weil mir ist es im
grunde genommen recht wenn im kurpark
das rasen kniehoch wex hauptsache meine
menschen dürfen immer noch im kurpark
gehen auch aus der tourismuszentrale
weil tourismus war heruntergefahren
dann kann man ja auch die mitarbeiter
darum bitten und hier immer jeder
mitgemacht und am ende des tages habe
ich natürlich auch viele vernünftige
rostockerinnen und rostocker habt ihr
auch mitgemacht haben auch sehr viel
bürgerhilfe also also gar nicht weg mit
co und ganz viele punkte mit corona viel
testen kontakt vor wald verfolgen die
verwaltung funktioniert professor stöhr
ist das eine sache wo man sagt das ist
genau ein richtiges modell auch für eine
längerfristige strategie nach der jetzt
eigentlich gesucht wird also die
pandemie kann man am besten
differenziert bekämpfung der pandemie
werden kann ich alle gleichmäßig stark
krank die todesfälle sind bei den
älteren gruppen die kontakte muss man
natürlich reduzieren aber auch wieder
konzentriert dort wo die hauptsächliche
infektionen stattfinden und man muss
auch regional differenzierte arbeiten
und haben hat das gemacht hat
differenziert geschaut da wo er
veränderungen vornehmen kann er hat noch
nichts gesagt über die alten und
pflegeheime wo das gesundheitsamt auch
immer noch weiterhin eingesetzt hat wo
die hygiene konzepte erarbeitet worden
wo auch fremdes personal die die
pflegeheim mitarbeiter unterstützt hat
zusätzliche
messungen durchgeführt waren aber auch
die hygiene konzepte kontrolliert wurden
von den hoch kompetenten kollegen aus
den gesundheitsämtern und die hygiene
konzepte umgesetzt hat und deswegen gibt
es auch bei ihm nicht diese große anzahl
an todesfällen die war landes war jetzt
sehen 30 prozent der todesfälle komme
aus drei prozent der der hochrisiko
population aus den alten pflegeheim und
da wurde sehr viel richtig gemacht wenn
man sich unheimlich viel
okay aber der ansatz dass man sagt man
muss mit dem virus leben ist dass der
ansatz den sie unterstützen ja das ist
natürlich nicht so genau dafür
differenzieren mit dem bios leben ich
weiß dass die pandemie dann vorbei ist
wenn das virus alle immun gemacht hat
oder besser noch schon alles mobilisiert
sind und haben wir das virus weiter
zirkulieren wie die anderen chronischen
auch langfristig werden wir uns darauf
einrichten wird das heißt natürlich
jetzt nicht die herren den schoß legen
das heißt natürlich jetzt die person die
am meisten betroffenen zu schützen das
heißt natürlich auch jetzt die studien
einzusetzen um zu sehen wie die anderen
bevölkerungsgruppen sich beteiligen und
das heißt doch jetzt sicherlich eine
positive agenda zu machen welche
maßnahmen man anzieht oder gezielt
lockert je nachdem wie sich die
situation entwickelt aber eben eine
längerfristige strategie wäre wichtig
herr meier sie haben mit anderen
wissenschaftlern und anderen disziplinen
dieses papier verfasst noko witt sie
wollen dass die infektionszahlen
richtungen null gehen heißt das nicht
dass wir uns dann auch für mehrere
wochen für auf einen sehr harten locker
und einstellen müssen
ja also wir haben dieses papier
gemeinsam in einer interdisziplinären
gruppe formuliert und die
grundüberlegungen dabei ist die die null
und da ist wichtig klarzustellen 0 heißt
nicht es gibt gar keine neuen
infektionen sondern 0 heißt genauso wie
im falle von rostock dass alle neuen
infektionen die auftreten auch komplett
getrennt werden müssen
das heißt es gibt keine unerklärten
plötzlich auftretenden neuinfektionen
das ist der dass es die wird das
wesentliche ziel die wesentliche
zielsetzung die wir in unserem papier
festgelegt haben als eine vision und
dann ist es rostock ist ein wunderbares
beispiel es gibt aber auch an
die städte münster etwa und in vielen
anderen ländern in europa und asien wo
man das beobachten kann wie kann man das
umsetzen und da ist eben die lokale
ebene extrem wichtig es wäre wunderbar
wenn man sich in deutschland quasi
rostock als vorbild nehmen könnte und
gucken kann wie kann man schnell
unbürokratisch vor des virus kommen dass
der ganz entscheidende wechsel den wir
brauchen wir müssen die in der
geschwindigkeit zulegen wir müssen die
quarantäne schneller machen wir müssen
viel mehr testen also auch diese
voraussicht zu haben diese dieses licht
im raum dass ein wunderbares bild
und damit können wir alle neuinfektionen
überwachen das heißt es gibt nur noch
die kontrollierte weiterverbreitung
wichtiger aber noch auch die
weiterverbreitung an sich auch zu
stoppen möglichst ja möglichst auf null
runter aber sehen wie schaffe ich das
natürlich hört sich irgendwie sierung ja
das hab ich da war nur wenn ich jetzt
wirklich ein harten lockdown macher nein
nein das ist nicht der fall also die wir
in grippel wir glauben nicht dass wir in
herten noch da auch in sondern in
schulau wirksameren western und lockt
dann nicht unbedingt ein hertha block
und da gibt es sehr viele hebel die die
hebel hat eine nationale gesagt also die
entscheidende rolle von expansiven
testen so dass man mehr testet proaktiv
auch in schulen hochrisikogruppen
natürlich aber auch personen die
besonders viele kontakte haben zb und
dann an anderer hebel der ganz
entscheidend ist ist die quarantäne ja
wenn sie es schaffen von dem zeitpunkt
in dem eine person infektiös wird zu dem
zeitpunkt an dem sie sich selbst selbst
verantwortlich in quarantäne beliebt
wenn sie diesen zeitpunkt verringern
können das ist ein gewaltiger hebel den
wir noch gar nicht so richtig genutzt
haben
und allein diese wenn wir das am tag und
um zwei tage verringern könnten würde es
keine neue welle geben kollegen an der
uni bonn mit einem wunderbaren werde
ausgerechnet mathematisch das ist
ziemlich sauer dass wir aber nur einer
dieser hebel wir haben auch noch aller
hygieneregeln wir haben auch noch das
abstandhalten das heißt wir haben
eigentlich das arsenal alles da er
trotzdem fragt man sich warum es nicht
funktioniert frau gabriele hat haben wir
den falschen lockdown hat die un oder
gibt es überhaupt im moment eine
richtige langfrist strategie der
bundesregierung gemeinsam mit den
ländern
man hat ja das klima alle 14 tage wird
dann neu geguckt und man hangelt sich
eben von von lockdown zu locken was alle
irgendwie sehr verrückt also gibt es
diese wichtige langfristig also wenn es
sie geben würde ist sie jedenfalls nicht
zu sehen also das was die
bundesregierung mit den ländern bisher
macht ist ja eher ein öffnen und wieder
anziehen und wieder öffnen wieder
anziehen was wirkt jede strategie
vermissen lässt und ich glaube die
beispiele gerade haben ja sehr deutlich
gemacht dass alles steht und fällt mit
dem engagement vor ort erstens also dass
da wirklich leute sind die pandemie
bekämpfung zu ihrer aufgabe auch machen
und das zweite ist und da glaube ich hat
die bundesregierung und auch die länder
auch in sehr schlechten job gemacht und
das zweite ist dass man einfache
maßnahmen durchführen kann die eine
große wirkung haben
also sprich maskenmann hätte von anfang
an auch sagen können
masken schützen wir geben jetzt masken
ab in euro in der maske das alles sich
schützen können also auch leute mit
kleinem budget zum beispiel dann sind
diese tests sehr teuer also wer kann
sich dann immer testen lassen
da hätte man sich auch überlegen müssen
ob diese tests zum selbstkostenpreis
angeboten werden können und dass sie
eben dann auch massenhaft durchgeführt
werden
also dieses konzept massentests und
masken für alle
das hätte man schon im märz und im april
machen können und es ist absolut
versäumt worden und ich glaube es ist
jetzt irgendwo durch das kommt
vielleicht hat man die studie nicht so
ernst genommen vielleicht hat man auch
das virus nicht so ernst genommen ich
eine mich ja noch gut dass eine große
debatte war ob man noch eine
die internationale woche in berlin
machen können als schon in china zu
sehen war dass das virus da war und es
gab natürlich in den ministerpräsidenten
konferenzen auch immer das gerangel der
ministerpräsidenten
wer lockert jetzt am meisten und muss
man wirklich so sehr an ziehen und die
endlosen debatten mit der kanzlerin und
die unterschiede oder auch das sagte
ministerpräsident erst sagt okay das ist
eine hysterie
wir müssen jetzt nicht schließen und
dann sind die fallzahlen in sachsen so
hoch dass eben doch geschlossen wird und
das ist eben keine strategie sondern das
ist ein hinterher rennen hinter dem
virus und das ist genau das gegenteil
von dem was im prinzip die kollegen hier
gesagt herr madsen wie war denn wie
wurden sie unterstützt haben sie sich
haben sie für sich gesagt okay ich mache
das jetzt ich bin denen ich kann das
jetzt mal für mich machen ich schau mal
was meine was die kollegen in dänemark
machen und ich ist es egal was die
ministerpräsidentin in mecklenburg
vorpommern sagt also kriegt man sie da
auch viel kritik ich hörte dass sie dass
sie am anfang dass das nicht so positiv
aufgenommen worden ist dass die so viel
getestet haben
naja ich glaube es war ein sehr
spezielles immer schon wo es für jeden
auch klar sein muss es gibt da keinen
punkt wo man genau nachlesen kann wie
hat man sich zu verhalten und sicherlich
ist das so wenn man ein bisschen
ausbricht dass man dann auch ja kritik
einstecken muss und das ist auch dann so
wie es ist was mir wie gesagt ganz
wichtig damals war ich habe die
verantwortung für 210.000 menschen und
deren gesundheit und deswegen habe ich
natürlich alles was ich konnte und was
sind meiner macht steht umgesetzt und
wie gesagt eine sehr gute zusammenarbeit
hier vor ort hinbekommen so dass wir
sehr viel testen konnte man hat damals
gesagt ich darf polizisten nicht testen
weil das ist so ein bisschen wie eine
bestechung und da war mein gegenargument
aber wenn sie sich auf ein schiff
befinden und dass sinkt und jemanden
kommt von der seite und bietet ihnen ein
rettungsboot an wenn das bestechung ist
dann nämlich trotzdem dieses
rettungsboot an frenzel mit einbringen
weil er eben gesagt wurde
wie das mit dem ganzen ist wenn ich
erzähle ich immer von einem rostocker
löwen wenn wir die menschen da draußen
erzählen würden ein löwe
ist im laufen dann würde kein mensch auf
die straße gehen wenn niemanden würde
wenn er einlösen dem supermarkt mitte
hin nimmt nicht auf abstand achten und
niemanden würde einen löwen mit im
pflegeheim nehmen und diese löse holt
bis zu 1000 menschen am tag von der
straße in deutschland und es gelingt uns
trotzdem nicht den menschen das bild
nicht zu erzählen wie gefährlich das
eigentlich ist mit dem was wir zu tun
haben und es wurde ihr mehrfach jetzt
gesagt das würde ich sofort begrüßen
testen testen testen es gibt schnell
fest dass es heute ein in dänemark dass
sie weist große vorteil von krieg nicht
nur deutsche nachrichten kann auch die
dänischen nachrichten immer lesen konnte
immer mitverfolgen wie in dänemark die
strategie mit dem lockdown um einiges
gemacht wurde festgestellt schnellstes
haben eine sicherheit bis zu 70 prozent
und ist extremst empfindlich auf mutter
schon dh wir könnten jetzt mit
schnellstes sofort erkennen weil dann
hol virenlast es und hohe wien last löst
sich wiederum in einem schnelltest aus
und ich wäre einfach dafür dass wir
verwaltungen firmen alle dazu bringen
dass sie wöchentlich alle mit sagte
einmal also alle die die unterwegs sind
den ich im mobilen arbeitskräften er
dann kriegen wir doch mal ein genaues
bild davon was los ist weil ich werde
auch künftig das war ja auch noch was
sollten weiter hat und niedrig sind
bleiben wir mal bei dem test moment
haben bleiben wir mal bei dem test sie
wollen dazu gerne auch was sagen ich bin
ja politikwissenschaftler und bin
deshalb eben auch sehr interessiert an
der frage wie warum wir auf landes und
bundesebene ebenso langsam reagiert
haben und warum das alles so ist und das
war ja ihre ausgangsfrage und man kann
natürlich einfach sagen na ja wir haben
eben keine saß erfahrungen wie viele
länder in asien und haben deshalb weder
in unseren in unserem regierungssystem
noch auf der ebene der bevölkerung das
bewusstsein dafür
das ist sicherlich ein wichtiger grund
das andere ist natürlich auch dass wir
uns kollektiv und ich entschuldige mich
bei allen die sozusagen ganz anders
gehandelt haben wie etwa die rostocker
verweigert haben von den besten
beispielen zu lernen und die besten
beispiele die findet man in europa die
findet man aber vor allem auch in
verschiedenen ländern
in asien und wir haben uns im prinzip
mit einer debatte aufgehalten
die sagt acht die sind alle inseln die
sind doch alle autoritär die kultur ist
alles ganz anders also die frage des
vergleichs ist ja der freien
philosophische frage anstatt in das
praktische zu gucken und zu sagen was
könnten wir vielleicht anpassen
adaptieren was könnten wir in diesem
unglaublich rapiden zeit wo alles
eskaliert wo man eben schnell sein muss
aber nicht perfekt was könnten wir
eigentlich hier anwenden und diese
offenheit dieses lernen das hat eben
absolut gefehlt und das ist glaube ich
etwas was uns extrem behindert hat und
was uns in diese situation gebracht hat
wer sie waren ja forschungskoordinator
für sah es bei der whu wird ihr rat
jetzt gefragt ja gerade jetzt
ich habe nur sagen ich hab viele
regierungen beraten und wenn ich das
gemacht aber dann sagst hat immer eine
interdisziplinäre arbeitsgruppe von
kollegen die nicht nur virologen
epidemiologen war das war noch
politikwissenschaftler das waren die
gesundheitsökonomen das sind auch
psychologen virtual oder im ganzen land
waren sie noch nicht
das muss ich ja auch nicht es gibt ja
tolle kollegen in deutschland lassen
dennoch zu dem dann sozusagen zu der
strategie genau die beobachtung die sie
haben nämlich dass man in deutschland
nicht von den anderen gelernt hat aber
auch nicht das eigene
forschungspotenzial genutzt hat sehen
wir jetzt gerade durch den mangel an
strategie meine der alexander der große
hatte die beim fußball gibt es die beim
unternehmen gibt die sogar beim schach
eine strategie warum haben wir keine
strategie für die pandemie bekämpfung
warum haben wir kein ziel lieber von dem
jetzt zustand für den zukünftigen
zustand kommen warum haben wir nicht die
kollektive das kollektive wissen da an
das ziel hat man ja worüber man streitet
ist ja der weg und lasse das ist einfach
die debatte die jetzt geführt wird und
über diese debatte vergisst man eben
einfach die schnellen maßnahmen die jede
aufgeführt worden sein ist ja ein jahr
haben die pandemie er hat nicht machen
in großen unternehmen ich habe auch in
großen unternehmen gearbeitet sagt man
dann mangel an führungskraft
wenn es halt kakophonie gibt von leuten
die alle glauben das richtige zu können
die gefragt werden ist ja heute so ich
werde gefragt 100
unsere geologen epidemiologen sagen ihre
meinung in england gibt es eine
einrichtung die heißt nerf takt das ist
eine gruppe von kollegen die viren vom
chief medical officer eingesetzt die
machen eine risikobewertung die haben
jetzt diese mutante risiko bewertet für
das gesundheitsministerium und die
meisten kollegen können sich die
aburteilung anschließend in deutschland
gibt es keine frage der verantwortung
auch nur wer hat jetzt eigentlich in der
pandemie die verantwortung und wer setzt
sie um
der bürgermeister von rostock fühlt dass
er diese verantwortung hat er seine
leute und setzt es um offenbar ist es
nicht überall so es ist es kann ja nicht
nur sein dass in berlin was beschlossen
wird und in den landeshauptstädten
es muss ja auch umgesetzt werden sie
haben noch ein wort vielleicht es gibt
ganze unternehmen die können innerhalb
einer woche in den lockdown gehen und
die arbeiten dann auch her
also das sind große unternehmen sind
banken alles mögliche dienst machen
unseren job du ja genau also die gehen
in thomas aber die verwaltung zum
beispiel die schafft es nicht in zehn
oder elf monaten auch ins home office zu
gehen und dort zu arbeiten und die
schaffen es eben nicht die
gesundheitsämter auszustatten mit leuten
die jetzt im home-office nicht so viel
zu tun haben und da fragt man sich doch
wer hat die verantwortung dafür warum
klappt das nicht herr meier sie wollen
dazu was sagen also das ist eine sehr
gute frage natürlich und aus politik
wissenschaftlicher sicht ist natürlich
klar wir sind föderales system ja und
eben gerade im gesundheitswesen ist
nicht nur alles sehr föderal organisiert
sondern auch stark lokal die ganzen
verantwortlichkeiten liegen bei den
gesundheitsämtern nur teilweise auf der
landesebene und weder der
bundesgesundheitsminister noch das
kanzleramt kann da einfach durchregieren
ja dass das braucht koordination des
braucht abstimmung und diese
koordination die wir bräuchten um vor
des virus zu kommen ja wir sind ja
individuell schlauer als das virus das
steht ja außer frage aber kollektiv
schaffen wir es nicht uns so schnell zu
koordinieren dass wir da vorkommen
und dass der föderalismus ist sozusagen
ein grund dafür beziehungsweise nicht
der föderalismus an sich aber die art
und weise wie in entscheidungsprozesse
gehandhabt werden aber der andere grund
und das da liegt schon sozusagen die
verantwortung ganz oben ist dass wir von
anfang an keine klare richtung hatten
also wir sind in ein loch dauern
reingestolpert letztes jahr im märz dann
sind wir aus dem loch down raus
gestolpert jetzt sind wir wieder in ein
lokal reingestolpert und jetzt stolpern
hier wieder raus in der öffnung und der
motivation her
das ist absehbar jetzt ist das
entscheidende
genau das ist er der entscheidende
unterschied von dem wo wir nicht gelernt
haben ist die erfolgreichen länder fast
alle länder asiens als ost asiens und
asien/pazifik was haben sie anders
gemacht die haben alle an irgendeinem
punkt früher oder später gesagt wir
setzen auf eine suppression strategie
wir wollen die weiterverbreitung des
virus so weit wie möglich einschränken
das hat taiwan gemacht als allererstes
dass vietnam gemacht das hat china china
gemacht das haben aber auch südkorea
gemacht und etwas später aber genau mit
dem gleichen prinzip australien und
neuseeland und diese und das ist auch
einer der das ist auch einer der
wesentlichen vorschläge in einem logo
mit papier
wir brauchen diese klare zielsetzung für
alle das klar ist jede maßnahme jede die
maßnahmen die wir treffen jede
instrument das wir ein setzen alle hebel
die wir haben müssen auf dieses ziel
ausgerichtet sein dass man kann
natürlich lokal unterschiedlich sein
sollen auch unterschiedlich aber wir
wollen ja nicht den föderalismus
abschaffen um ein präparat ein wahllokal
das ist das zentrale aber man schafft es
ja nur wenn die leute wird wenn die
bürger eben mit machen es und es
akzeptieren und da würde ich gerne mal
sie fragen auch herr massen wie schaffen
sie ist dass ihre dass die
rostockerinnen und rostocker sagen ja
wir machen das mit und wir halten uns an
die regeln oder kontrollieren sie extrem
viel
ja wir sind sehr strengen der kontrolle
also ich habe ein großes vertrauen in
meine bürgerinnen und bürger sie sind
auch sehr vernünftig da habe ich sehr
viel glück dass so viele vernünftige
menschen in rostock leben
aber auch das gehört dazu wenn man
jemanden sagt ich habe in euch vertrauen
muss man trotzdem auch sehr stark
kontrollieren
das gehört nun mal zu dem paket dazu
aber was ich gerne in dem was ebenso ein
bisschen entstand mal mit geben will ist
weil du ganz viel gesagt wird wir wir
sind in deutschland auf es fad aufsicht
oder sozusagen wir glaube ich ich habe
ihr das gefühl wir sind unterwegs mit
300 km/h und gucken im rückspiegel weil
wir immer im sieben tage ins identen
hier niemand sagt was machen eigentlich
in festtage in vier wochen in sechs
wochen in zwei monate
das wäre für mich eine echte strategie
und jetzt kommt dass du das was ich
wirklich sehr schwierig empfinde ein
bundeskanzlerin hat natürlich die
verantwortung für ganz deutschland und
ein ministerpräsidentin oder präsident
für ein land ein bürgermeister ist aber
ganz nah bei seinen bürgerinnen und
bürger und ist ein wahnsinniges spagat
wenn ich darum rufe und belasten ich
bitte meine schulen eröffnen
kinder brauchen kinder kinder aber auch
in bildung und dann geschieht was
schlimmes ein kind oder vielleicht an
lehrerin erkrankt ganz schwer oder
vielleicht verstirbt dann wird jeder
sagen was war das für ein blöder
bürgermeisters doch damals gewollt wenn
ich's nicht mache
was hat das für konsequenzen und in
diesem spagat lassen wir sehr viele
kommunalpolitiker auf allen ebenen wir
müssen jeden tag eine entscheidung
treffen
die entweder für das eine odere für das
andere ist haben wir uns also von
richtig schwierige aufgabe und genau
deswegen brauchen wir diese strategie
also diese was wie ich sagte
überraschungen
wir sind ja bald pilot zu sein weil ich
nur ein ganz kleiner aspekt nicht
wirklich wichtig finden sagt weil das
schlimme ist ich weiß ganz genau dass
wir am 10 januar drei mögliche szenarien
haben die zahlen sind bestiegen gleich
geblieben oder gefallen
das schlimme ist aber dass wir auf allen
drei szenarien die gleiche antwort
hätten nämlich wenn sie gestiegen werden
jetzt müssen wir die maßnahmen
festhalten sonst steigt weiter wenn sie
gleich geblieben sind
wenn wir nicht jetzt festhalten bleiben
die nicht gleich und wenn es gefallen
wäre das dürfen jetzt nicht aufs spiel
setzen deswegen müssen wir die maßnahmen
festhalten
also wenn ich eine strategie hat die die
gleiche antwort hat dann habe ich keine
spiele haben und ich würde gerne
wir wissen woran soll man das handeln
messen hersteller investiert wir haben
jetzt immer diese 50er intelligenz das
ist irgendwie unser maßstab oder müsste
es die todes müssen uns die todeszahlen
sein oder müsste ist das wirtschaftliche
wachstum sein was ist heute wieder
bekanntgabe das ist eben nicht mehr
stark wächst es gibt viele viele
unternehmen die wahrscheinlich in die
insolvenz gehen müssen also wo man sich
natürlich auch sorgen macht wie es hier
vielen menschen geht also wonach sollen
wie das da was ist unser maßstab bei der
maßstab kann ich ein eindimensional sein
muss hier sicherlich zweidimensional
fahren die erste und wichtigste frage
ist wie entwickeln sich die todeszahlen
und woher kommen tatsächlich die
todesfälle und da haben wir ja schon
eine antwort und hätten hätten wir schon
einen ansatzpunkt für eine strategie die
zweite frage die ehre welche eine
altenpflegeheime hier muss er natürlich
hier ganz konzentriert vollgas ohne
kompromisse alle ressourcen die man hat
hingeben 30 prozent der todesfälle
kommen aus drei prozent der
risikopatienten also dass der eine tag
tut man aber auch noch nicht wie würde
man macht das aber auch jemand sagen
würde dass nicht nur bestätigen
und der vorteil den man hier noch machen
kann das machen muss ist dass man
natürlich auf die allgemeine situation
in der population schaden und hier guckt
man sich an was sind die haupt
infektionsquellen und da wissen wir ja
dass die daten oder fall eintrag in die
alten pflegeheim durch das personal
passiert muss man dann auch wieder
investieren
ich kann nicht verstehen wie das
zulassen der kindergärten und schulen
eine verbesserung bei den alten und
pflegeheim machen würde dann die letzten
sechs wochen wir an die schulen ja schon
fast zu und verstört einfach eine ganz
klare antwort drauf und das ist da gibt
es eine ganz klare fertigmachen der
stelle er zu ende und ein programm hin
und dann herr meier
das heißt also man muss zwei dimension
erfahren auf die risikogruppen achten
und natürlich auch auf die gesamt
instanz in der population der zweite
kriterium ist intensivstationen
ihr könnt auf keinen fall die situation
eintreten dass vielleicht mehr als 25
vielleicht 20 bis 25 prozent der
intensivstation mit corinna patienten
belegt sind das muss zehn prozent muss
dann oben noch frei bleiben der rest
muss da sein für die notfall
patienten auch für die krebspatienten
und die krankenhaus belegung muss man
sich anschauen und der die notation dass
der tod in den altenheimen in den
kindergarten beginnt ist zynisch für
mich und hochgradig unwissenschaftlich
dass es auch nicht belegt man schließt
die augen davor dass es sehr gute
studien die besten zu hause fast aus
deutschland gibt die belegen dass die
kinder sich nicht nur weniger infizieren
auch selbst sondern das virus weiter
geben und selbst in ihrer eltern das
virus weiter geben und sich sehr weniger
infizieren lassen für den deutschland
also die augen sagt man hier auch von
den erwachsenen nicht verschließen
bleiben wir mal bei den alten und
pflegeheimen bei den hohen todestag und
das ist glaube ich das größte versäumnis
was man sagen muss der bundesregierung
die kanzlerin hat eine
jahrhundertkatastrophe ausgerufen das
ist ein sehr großes wort ein superlativ
und in den maßnahmen wird eben nicht
dieser superlativ umgesetzt man hätte
wirklich sofort die bundeswehr für jedes
altenheim setzen müssen mit
teststationen mit tests für alle die da
rein und rausgehen und zwar
verpflichtend aber und das könnte man ab
sofort machen
das problem ist man hat einfach immer zu
viel gesagt bitte macht das und es
sollte passieren und man hat sie nicht
verpflichtet und wenn man die
verteidigungsministerin fragt warum
nicht die bundeswehr jetzt bei den
altenheim testet dann sagt sie ja wir
werden nicht gerufen oder wir werden
nicht gewollt das muss man auch mit
einbezogen also ich finde den einzelnen
high von den einzelnen heimbetreibern
zum beispiel und der finanzminister sagt
wir haben ja das geld bereit gestellt
für die tests aber die tests waren
trotzdem nicht durchgeführt also und da
glaube ich liegt ein großes versäumnis
dass man einfach sagt die müssen jetzt
geschützt werden es muss verpflichten
der stadt rain und dem das mittel dazu
wäre einfach dass man diese
jahrhundertkatastrophe eben auch auf
umsätze und sagt wir haben jetzt ein
katastrophenzustand und in diesem
zustand ist es erlaubt weil ausgenommen
gerade eine art katastrophenfall aus
luft und sagt es ist jetzt erlaubt dass
die bundeswehr testet und es muss sein
dass sie da testen ist kommt sonst
keiner mehr rein also dass man nicht nur
bittet sondern umsätzen für ihr seid
heute gemacht die schon heute gesagt die
10.000
merkel reist die usa im vergleich zur
kehre ich glaube er wollte jetzt mal
sagen hermann ja ich glaube diese test
debatte wir können das natürlich ewig
erweitern aber das ist klar wir müssen
expansiv testen das grundprinzip und
dann genau wie herr stöhr sagt muss man
sehr klar co hingucken wo muss man die
tests massieren also wo braucht man die
mehr und es einst sind die risikogruppen
das andere sind aber auch
ausbruchsgeschehen also wenn sie ein
starkes ausbruchsgeschehen wo haben dann
dann müssen sie da auch mal reingehen
und massen tests durchführen sowie das
auch vielerorts jetzt gemacht wird
um eben dies ganze lagebild ausleuchten
zu können und das ist also wir sehen
dass zb aus china
wenn in der großstadt in china ein
einziger fall auftritt der nicht
getrackt werden kann also der nicht wo
nicht die infektionskette nachvollzogen
werden können dann kann es sein dass die
ganze stadt vielleicht mit zehn
millionen zweimal einen pcr-test macht
also diesen hochwertigen labortest macht
umgeht alles wirklich zu finden und
gedübelt man die aktion rotationen
finden die mutter also die mutation
hängt von den tests ab denen man
verwendet das nochmal die mutation ist
noch mal eine andere frage aber das
entscheidende ist und david über dich
gerne herrn stöhr widersprechen warum
können wir nicht sozusagen sich das
virus weiter verbreiten lassen den
schülern und bei anderen also zunächst
mal es gibt ganz viele studien die
zwischen eindeutig zeigen da ist die
sachlage etwas anders das eben auch
schulen und schüler deutlich in der
weiterverbreitung beteiligt sind das
eine das andere ist wir dürfen nicht nur
auf die todeszahl gucken wir müssen auch
auf die longo wird effekte gucken also
auf leute jüngere ältere kinder die sich
anstecken mit kurve teilweise gar keinen
starken ist symptom verlauf haben aber
trotzdem langfristige folgen haben und
auch das ist wichtig im blick zu
behalten nicht nur die todeszahlen und
deswegen ziehen ist ganz sicher sicher
wenn wir das nicht schaffen
moment moment ist er jetzt momentan
stehe jetzt bin ich dran hersteller
bitte lassen sie mich aus denn das
prinzip ist ein ganz einfaches wenn wir
es nicht schaffen die weiterverbreitung
in vielen anderen bevölkerungsgruppen zu
stoppen und sehr weit zu unterdrücken
dann können wir auch nie die heime
schützen weil es gibt immer die
verbindung die leute gehen immer dahin
haben die ärzte haben selber familien
die kinder gehen zur schule
das ist unmöglich ok ja ja meist aber in
der konsequenz eben kitas und schulen zu
lassen
nein das heißt liegt in der konsequenz
kitas und schulen zu lassen sondern
genau wie herzen sagt die
gesundheitsämter müssen in der lage sein
alle infektionsketten zu treffen da es
dazu hat man die 50er inzidenz
festgelegt aber dies eindeutig zu hoch
rostock schafft bei 30 oder 40 bei 60
herzen verbessern sie mich oder so sagen
sie mir ob das stimmt bei 60 würde ich
sagen wahrscheinlich ihr gesundheitsamt
könnte es auch nicht mehr treffen
das ist der poesie sowie die inzidenz
möglichst weit runter fahren müssen ok
herzen wie ist es bei ihnen mit den
alten und pflegeheimen und wie schaffen
sie es also bis zu welcher inzidenz
haben sie selber wo sie sagen bis dahin
schaffen wir das noch mit der
nachverfolgung wir haben quasi vom
ersten tag an bis auf dem elfen oder
zehnter januar weiß inzwischen was mit
der silvester meldungen waren wir ja nie
über 50 wer da bei mir glaube ich einmal
ganz kurz über 50 daher kann ich sagen
da bist der grenze schafft man es auf
jeden fall aber man muss deutlich
ausbauen
den bereich wir haben auch eine digitale
meldesystem in unserer gesundheitsamt
und wir haben auch digitale logbücher
für menschen die in quarantäne sind man
stellt übrigens sehr schnell fest auch
bei sehr niedrigen zahlen ist man ganz
schnell über 1000 leute in quarantäne
hat und was ich aber sagen wollte wir
haben es auch versäumt immer die finger
in die wunde zu legen
wir kennen keine fälle wo menschen sich
angesteckt haben beim schuhekaufen im
schuhladen am haben aber die schulen
geschlossen
wir wissen aber einen familien feiern
gab es ein problem wir hier oben und das
hat mich lange gewundert lassen
pendelverkehr aus polen oder anderen
länder zu weil wir sagen ja sonst kommen
die pflegekräfte nicht ran ja ich sage
ich glaube es ist besser es kommt nicht
eine infizierte pflegekraft rein und man
hätte diese pendelverkehr geschlossen
und wenn man genauer hinschaut ist es so
ein bisschen als ob wir uns davor
gedrückt haben die ware probleme
auszusprechen sagen das ist die familie
frey ist sind die familien
zusammenkommen
er war es erst das fliegen aber das muss
man ja dann auch kontrollieren
also muss ja dann müsste man ja aber der
familien daher rein
ich würde von einem fall hier wo mir
jemand berichtete die sind in
pflegeheimen rein gekommen weil wir ja
so niedrige zahlen haben ohne ein test
daraufhin haben wir natürlich sofort
eine kontrolle hingeschickt ich mache
das sehr gerne dass ich hier oben sehr
deutlich machen wir sind die ganze zeit
unterwegs ich will nie mehr touristen
sehen
ich will wissen auf ein benchmark ob wir
genauso viel unser heim mit festen sie
sind dazu verpflichtet wir unterstützen
sie aber da würde ich auch gerne mal so
eben gesagt wurde es könne doch überall
die bundeswehr das soll nicht
despektierlich gegenüber die bundesweit
klingen aber es ist nicht jeder mitglied
vom bundeswehr in der lage festungen
durchzuführen braucht schon gewisse
medizinische grundvoraussetzungen stehen
und machen es okay aber das muss auch
umgesetzt werden das ist gar nicht so
leicht wie es immer klingt erfordert in
einer nachverfolgung für zelte aufbauen
eine menge aufgaben übernehmen aber man
muss schon selber die verantwortung
ärmel hoch und in der eigenen verwaltung
seine leute ausbilden und dann die
unterstützung natürlich ist es gut dass
wir die bundeswehr die eigene verwaltung
zu nehmen es gar keine frage aber wenn
das eben heißt die verwaltung kann es
nicht mache oder die
verwaltungsmitarbeiter können da nicht
hin geschickt werden dann muss eben die
bundeswehr her das ist ja nur die
rückfall position warum haben ist es so
schwierig mit der verwaltung jeden
montag hört man immer die zahlen sind
nicht kann man sich nicht verlässlich
die zahlen vom robert-koch-institut weil
das gesundheitsamt eben am wochenende
gearbeitet dann würden wir jetzt seit
monaco oder telefonisch von 9 bis 17 uhr
geschah aber von tarom frau carmen
erklären sie sind also warum schaffen
wir es nicht in einer in einer
katastrophenlage zu sagen es gibt keine
normalen beruf stunden weil ich glaube
dass es wieder eine frage der
verantwortung und wie jeder diese lage
selber einschätzt es gibt eben
bürgermeister wie herrn madsen die sagen
wir müssen das jetzt zu unserer
chefsache machen und es gibt andere die
sagen wir kommen da schon durch wir
haben eben wenig instanzen und es ist
auch wieder ein versäumnis von vielen
ländern also bayern hat zum beispiel den
katastrophenfall ausgerufen
die konnten dann auch
das zentral organisieren und vernetzen
und so weiter brandenburg hat es zum
beispiel nicht gemacht brandenburg hat
seine verwaltung ins home office
geschickt nur mit einem usb stick aber
ohne computer und die sitze neben dann
da und die werden eben aber nicht weil
die vorschriften nicht geändert wurden
in gesundheitsämter in großem stil
geschickt die sie zu nehmen dann zu
hause und ich glaube das ist wieder ein
versäumnis der bürokratie einfach da
länder auch dann vielleicht zu sehr mit
der kontakt hatte ja aber wenn die
anderen ist die wirklich die
digitalisierung also wir reden seit
jahren über die digitalisierung ist die
wissen wie alles funktioniert nahrungs
und im letzten jahr das muss man
vielleicht auch noch wissen sind sechs
milliarden digital gelder bereitgestellt
wurden davon sind 590 millionen
abgeschlossen worden
und da fragt man sich warum warum
bestellen die nicht laptops computer
warum passiert ist also herzen sie
wollten jetzt dazu noch was ganz so
bürokratie wenn ich das richtig
verstanden habe
ja ich glaube eine sache die ich würde
sehr sehr gerne die gesundheitsämter
einmal in schutz nehmen weil das auch
schnell im raum steht wenn man mal dass
ein bisschen auch wieder bildlich
aufstellt würde ich sagen dass das
corona virus ein formel 1 rennen ist und
dass wir unser gesundheits eben daran
staates gestellt haben mit rostige
fahrräder und den leuten zu sagen so
sieht man zu dass wir jetzt das rennen
gewinnen ist wirklich ein stück weit
unfair
die sind ja überhaupt nicht dafür gebaut
gewesen ein normales gesundheitsamt
steht vor ganz normale herausforderungen
tag tägliches brot und auf einmal kommt
ein pandemie wird kann ich habe ihnen
unseren damals unser katastrophenlager
reingeschaut und erfahren alles was wir
da an schutz material haben ist 2012
abgelaufen
unser pandemiepläne ist von
irgendjemandem lang ist es ausgelegt
aber ich erzähle haben wir klar aber in
den zehn monaten hätte man ihnen ja
zumindest mal irgendwie einen normalen
kleinwagen hinstellen können also man
den boden bleiben das ist jetzt meine
mitarbeiter tatsächlich auch in einen
zumindestens fast immer ein test er soll
wir haben wir haben tolle sagen jemand
der fragen können sie auch nicht
installieren ohne führerschein
okay aber da ich würde gern diese
letzten sechs noch mehr nutzen um mal zu
schauen was schaffen wir jetzt wir
schauen auf die impfung da haben wir ja
da hakt es auch da haben wir jetzt
probleme mit mit mit der mit den
lieferungen zerstört wenn sie jetzt in
der bund länder kommission sitzen und
sie sitzen damit am tisch was sagen sie
jetzt was muss jetzt passieren ab dem
der lok dann geht jetzt bis 14 februar
alle sind verrückt gerade auch die
familien mit kindern die zu hause sind
was man sollte passieren das wäre die
erste wichtigste maßnahme die erste und
wichtigste maßnahme wäre das für einen
transparenten vorhersagbaren stufen plan
entwickeln wie wir mit elastischen
maßnahmen uns an die notwendigkeit der
eskalation und deeskalation der
maßnahmen in den nächsten monaten
anpassen müssen wir müssen indikatoren
vorgeben
die ihn sich in bestimmten zielkorridor
befinden das könnte der wert sein das
könnten die intelligenten sein als das
spezifisch es wäre das was er da ein
guter indikator ihrer meinung wissen
meine prinzip war ja immer pandemieplan
und strategieentwicklung ist eine
kollektive sache ich kann mich jetzt
hier allein gestellt und zahlen nennen
aber das was herr günther macht zum
beispiel in schleswig-holstein ist genau
der richtige weg die haben jetzt ein
paar nämlich stufen plan entwickelt wie
sie in vier stufen transparent
vorhersagbar
sicherlich kann man nur noch kritisieren
die zeit und auch vorhersagbar den
menschen zeigen können wie wir in den
nächsten monaten vorgehen werden welche
parameter werden sich verändern in
welche richtung was kann dann gelockert
werden oder muss sogar noch angezogen
werden das ist das was die leute
brauchen eine positive länder wo sie
sehen wie es weitergeht und es tut mir
leid zu sagen wir sind leider in europa
in mitteleuropa als ich nach asien zu
wenden in tropische länder wo die viren
ganz anderes zirkulieren oder dann auch
auf der einen seite sagen wir haben ein
bestimmtes politisches system das ist
wie es ist und wir haben schwierigkeiten
auf der anderen seite sagen ja wir
müssen das trotzdem hinkriegen das
wunschdenken darf nicht zur strategie
werden
deswegen glaube ich wenn man nach vorne
schaut stufenplan und ich hoffe dass
diese pandemie planung so infektiös ist
wieder okay herr meyer was würden sie
denn jetzt sagen weil sie wollen ja
dieses jahr an die snuko witt papier
verfasst mit den anderen
wissenschaftlern zusammen also dieses
runterbringen also wenn sie jetzt da am
tisch sitzen im kanzleramt was ist ihre
strategie ist das wichtigste
die erste wichtigste maßnahmen also
zunächst es zunächst einmal wichtig zu
sagen asien besteht ja um noch einmal zu
dem vergleich zu kommen die ich aus
tropischen ländern vergleichen sie mal
soll die gerade zum zweiten mal einen
größeren ausbruch komplett zurück
gedrängt haben und die instanzen massiv
nach unten gedrängt haben dass es im
winter soll hat eine ein grad ein grad
kälter im schnitt im winter wie berlin
hatte aber ungefähr dreimal so viel
einwohner und die bevölkerungsdichte ist
viermal so hoch dh wenn man wenn man
also etwa nimmt dann sieht man dass
diese strategie der vorschlagen auch im
winter funktioniert und in südkorea
nebenbei gesagt gab es gar nicht
lockdown das entscheidend ist also da
stimme ich aber mit herrn
stöhr überein wir brauchen eine
planungssicherheit wir brauchen einen
klaren plan ob der stufen hat oder
greens wie wir vorschlagen das ist sogar
im prinzip vereinbar wir brauchen klare
maßnahmen und noch wichtiger eine klare
kommunikation was passiert was wir jetzt
haben ist in natanz anstalt einer
strategie und dementsprechend auch die
kommunikation die mal so mal so ist und
dann verliert man eben ganz viele leute
wer muss erlebte war auch ihr servus den
ton angeben ist es die kanzlerin dann
hängt es wirklich also das muss
gemeinsam von den ministerpräsidenten
kommen die kanzlerin hat zwar die
autorität als kanzlerin aber die
zuständigkeit liegt bei den
ministerpräsidenten das muss klar von
denen kommen die vergleichsgröße präsent
scheidenden umsetzungs ebene und die und
die kommt die ist auf der lokalen ebene
und deshalb so schön dass herr madsen
heute da ist da passiert das spielt
eigentlich die musik ja da hat man
entweder ein tesla oder ein fahrrad
zugleich darin zwei dinge wichtig einen
ton kann man es auch nennen als beispiel
die bringen wir die leute dazu aktiver
mitzumachen
auch diese pandemie demokratischer zu
machen dass man nicht nur einfach
befolgt was kommt sondern dass man
selber teilnehmen kann und die also die
schnelltests wie jeder machen könnte
werden immer nach eigenen das mittel
dazu kann jeder machen jeden tag
gereinigt und habt noch einiges gut an
mitgliedern das zu wort kommt nach
berlin
also was aber wohl sagen sie jetzt auch
mit der kommunikation ist es liegt an
der kanzlerin hängt an den
ministerpräsidenten der muss da jetzt ja
ich glaube dann ist einfach alle jetzt
sich am riemen reißen und die
verantwortung begreifen die sie alle
haben und natürlich kann die kanzlerin
mit den ministerpräsidenten wieder ein
plan mache aber ich würde vorschlagen
dass man nochmal jetzt die woche
bundestag nutzt noch mal diese ganze
lage offen zu debattieren und daraus
schlüsse zu ziehen und nächste woche ist
ja schon wieder koalitionsausschuss und
dass man sich da auf den stufen plan
einigt und den dann auch durchzieht
herr madsen werden sie gehört in
schwerin von der ministerpräsident fragt
die sie um rat damit die mit ihren
ratschlägen dann hier nach berlin reisen
kann
na ja unser ministerpräsident ist auf
jeden fall so dass jemand so einen
großen mv plan einlädt wo bürgermeister
und landräte diskutieren können das
heißt wir haben
guten demokratischen prozess sie hat
natürlich ein ganz anderes regelungs
gebiet als wir als bürgermeister und
muss deswegen ja immer schauen dass sie
für alle landeskinder eine gute lösung
finden aber ich wollte eigentlich an
bringen ich glaube nicht dass wir wieder
nach berlin schauen soll sondern jeden
klarmachen muss nicht eingesetzt nicht
eine verordnung wird das virus am ende
besiegelt aber das verhalten von jedem
einzelnen von uns also ein ganz starkes
kind kommt auf dich an
es kommt nicht ruft nicht nach dem staat
sondern benimm dich so wie es
letztendlich vorgeschrieben wird und
dann haben wir eine sehr gute chance
aber da sieht man hat ja den anderen
dass sie das schaffen in rostock wie
kriegen sie das hin
also diese diese ansprache der bürger
dass sie damit machen ziel und energie
immer wieder direkte ansprache und auch
kritisieren wenn es angebracht ist wenn
ich höre da klappt nicht im pflegeheim
da bin ich sehr laut in der zeitung und
samstag bin ich sehr lobend weil ich das
glück habe dass hier viele vernünftige
menschen sind und ich will es immer
wieder nur besuchen kein gesetz kein
verordnung schreibe ich nach dem start
der wird das nicht eindämmen
das ist ja ein kampf gegen der
bevölkerung hält im kampf gegen den
virus ok und denen sollte jeder selber
aufnehmen vielen dank herr madsen nach
rostock wenn wir wieder reisen dürfen
freuen wir uns mal nach rostock zu
kommen vielen dank herr meier nachbarn
ja und frau gammelin vielen dank
danke fürs zuschauen morgen gibt es
wieder eine phoenix runde den morgen
wird das urteil gesprochen im mordfall
lübke und dann schauen wir uns schauen
wir auf die rechts extreme bedrohung es
freut mich wenn sie wieder dabei sind
das war die phoenix runde
jetzt folgt für nichts der tag
[Musik]